in this video we'll talk about monoamine
oxidase inhibitor or MAO inhibitors
MAO inhibitors are useful to treat
depression
and it acts via altering the level of
dopamine
in simple words it prevents the
degradation of dopamine dopamine once
released in the synaptic cleft does not
persist for long it gets re-uptaken by
specific dopamine Transporters and
inside the presynaptic terminal it would
be eventually converted to 3-4
dihydroxyphenyl acetic acid and thereby
it would be metabolized
now the monoamine oxidase Inhibitors
inhibit the monoamine oxidase which
actually
helps in conversion of dopamine into
other intermediates
and thereby it makes dopamine more
persistent
now dopamine is a neurotransmitter and
this is really important for brain
function
dopamine is involved in motivation
reward Euphoria so it's basically a feel
good Factor
now let us try to understand dopamine
biosynthesis to appreciate the function
of MAO inhibitors in bit more details so
dopamine is synthesized from the amino
acid tyrosine which gets converted to
lldopa and eventually gets converted to
dopamine
now this dopamine gets reuptaken in the
presynaptic cleft and dopamine gets
degraded via several mechanism one
mechanism is via monoamine oxidase
it converts dopamine into three four
dihydroxyphenyl acetic acid also another
enzyme known as cathical o methyl
transferase or comt converts dopamine
into three methoxytyramine
eventually these intermediates get
converted to homovalignic acid and
thereby dopamine is degraded
now there are several Inhibitors such as
MAO inhibitors also comt Inhibitors
which can prevent this metabolization
and allow the dopamine to stay for
longer longer the dopamine duration
better would be the cognitive ability
and better would be Euphoria or feel
good Factor right
now there are several FDA approved MAO
inhibitors such as stated here some of
them are taken orally some of them have
can be also applied via transdermal
patch
now MAO inhibitors are among the
earliest developed antidepressant these
days they are actually replaced by
better antidepressants
but MAO inhibitors can increase blood
pressure if not taken adequately or if
not taken with proper food
so overall MAO inhibitors might have
side effects and consequences
there are several food which contains
tyramine means amine derivative of the
tyrosine amino acid so basically uh
banana curated meat cheese Beer all
these things contain tyramine dopamine
is also a tyrosine derivative
in situations when MAO inhibitors are
used dopamine level is already high in
the blood
in that context if you put or eat more
tiram in containing food
there would be too much tyramine
concentration in the plasma that can
abruptly change the blood pressure and
increase it causing hypertension so this
is the biggest caution to be followed
while consuming uh any dopamine inhibit
or dopamine degradation Inhibitors or
MAO inhibitors
so there are several side effects
such as nausea headache dry mouth
dizziness skin reaction or rashes
insomnia but all of these side effects
are not common for every individual for
each individual the side effects could
vary
it is not really safe to take MAO
inhibitors during pregnancy because it
can affect the baby's development or
even it can pass from mother to baby
during breastfeeding
now the drug Mouse Inhibitors can also
interact with other drugs such as
painkillers especially aspirins also
medications for cold and Allergy and
antidepressants so obviously a clinician
need to know about your medical history
before prescribing the MAO inhibitors
but MAO inhibitors work very nicely for
many individuals for whom other
antidepressant doesn't work
so it's important so obviously consult a
doctor before using MAO inhibitors so I
hope this was useful if you want more
notes and flashcards you can follow me
on Facebook or Instagram link are in the
description you can also support our
Channel via super thanks you can pay via
paytm PayPal or UPI see you in next
video